From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass, and the theme of today's show is, This I Used to Believe.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯，今天节目的主题是“我曾经相信”。
And I have to admit this is just a knockoff of this series that's been running on NPR News called, This I Believe, which in turn, actually is a knockoff of the This I Believe Series that Edward R. Murrow did in the 1950s.
我必须承认，这只是对NPR新闻那档名为“我信”的系列的模仿，而那个系列本身其实又是对爱德华·R·默罗在20世纪50年代所做的“我信”系列的模仿。
Maybe you've heard some of these on the radio. These are short essays, three minutes long, by famous people and not so famous people very often, about what life has taught them.
或许你在广播里听过其中一些内容。这些都是三分钟长的短文，通常由名人或普通人讲述，关于生活教会了他们什么。
The NPR series actually invited listeners from all over the world to write in with their own short essays about what they believe in. And 65,000 people responded. 65,000. I was talking to Jay Allison, who heads the team that sorted through the essays and edited the ones that ended up on the radio, and he he told me that while only 200 of the essays actually ended up on the air, all 65,000 went on to this website that they set up.
这个NPR系列实际上邀请了世界各地的听众写下自己的短文，讲述他们的信仰。有65000人作出了回应。65000人。我曾与负责整理这些文章并编辑出最终广播内容的团队负责人杰伊·艾利森交谈，他告诉我，虽然只有200篇文章最终上了广播，但所有65000篇文章都收录在了他们建立的网站上。
You know, if you go to the website, you can type in any word. I'd started typing in words. I typed like, squid. 11 essays mention squid. Car bomb, 20. Death, 7,000 and some.
你知道，如果你访问那个网站，你可以输入任何词。我试着输入了一些词。比如“乌贼”，有11篇文章提到了乌贼。“汽车炸弹”，20篇。“死亡”，7000多篇。
Wait, what were the squid ones? People didn't believe in squid, right? Squid was just an ancillary prop.
等等，关于乌贼的是什么内容？人们不应该信仰乌贼吧？乌贼只是个辅助道具。
Squid, squid came in--
乌贼，乌贼出现在——
We were having squid and I realized--?
我们当时正在吃乌贼，我意识到——？
Well, one of the ones I read, was the guy was writing it and had recorded it in a deep sea submersible. He was working, I think, for Greenpeace and he was in the Arctic ocean. And he was looking out the window and seeing squid and writing his essay.
好吧，我读过的其中一篇，是一个人在深海潜水器里录制的。我想他当时为绿色和平组织工作，身处北冰洋。他看着窗外，看到了乌贼，于是写下了他的文章。
That guy, of course, wrote about how he believed in cocktail sauce. Not really.
那个人当然是写他相信鸡尾酒酱。其实不是的。
The big things that came up over and over in the essays that people sent in were really exactly what you would expect. People believe in kindness, and the Golden Rule, tolerance, social justice, love, hard work, humility. By the fourth year of the This I Believe series, it got a lot harder to get on the air-- if you believed in kindness.
人们寄来的文章中反复出现的核心内容，完全是你意料之中的。人们相信善良、黄金法则、宽容、社会正义、爱、勤奋和谦逊。在“我信”系列开播的第四年，如果你想谈论对“善良”的信仰，想要上广播就变得困难得多了。
Now, I don't want you to get mean about people. Are there some where you and your team read the essays and you just wonder like, "Wow, what were they thinking?"
我不想让你对别人刻薄。有没有哪篇文章让你和你的团队读完后想说：“天哪，他们都在想些什么？”
There've been some written by people of-- who are very advantaged. And they've written about why they deserve their advantages. And those are somewhat shocking to me. And--
确实有一些文章出自非常优越的人之手。他们写的是他们为什么应得这些优越条件。这些让我感到有些震惊。而且——
And who would write this kind of thing?
那会是什么样的人写这种东西呢？
Teenagers with money sometimes write about how they deserve it. I was searching for one actually today, and I remembered that they'd mentioned like a BMW, I think in it. So I just did a search on BMW, but then I started scanning them, and a lot of people wrote about a belief in their car. In the brand of car they had. Those essays take me aback a little bit.
有钱的青少年有时会写他们为什么应得这些财富。其实我今天正好在找一篇，我记得他们提到了比如宝马车之类的东西。所以我搜了一下“宝马”，但后来我开始浏览这些文章，很多人写的是对汽车的信仰。对他们拥有的汽车品牌的信仰。那些文章让我有点吃惊。
One of the essays about cars, the person said, "I believe in having a car as cute as I am." And she believed she was much cuter than her car, her current car. And so she believed that-- I forget whether it was a BMW or an Audi-- but that was the car that she--
其中一篇关于汽车的文章，写作者说：“我相信拥有一辆像我一样可爱的车。”她认为自己比她目前的车要可爱得多。所以她相信——我忘了是宝马还是奥迪——那是她认为……的车。
She thought would be as cute as her?
她认为那辆车会像她一样可爱？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah?
是吗？
Jay says that it's become a popular thing to assign This I Believe essays to kids in high school. There's a whole curriculum around it. And it is clear a lot of the kids do not want to do the essays. Some of them just seem to look around the room and just pick something-- "I believe in pencils,"-- and then start writing.
杰伊说，给高中生布置“我信”的作文已经成了一件流行的事情。这周围有一整套课程。很明显，很多孩子并不想写这些作文。有些人似乎只是环顾教室，然后随便挑个东西——“我相信铅笔”——然后就开始写了。
There are schools all over this country who are using This I Believe. There is a generation of children who are going to curse our names.
全国各地的学校都在使用“我信”这个项目。有一代孩子长大后会咒骂我们的名字。
That's right. They're hearing you on the radio right now. They're sitting in the backseat of the car and then, "Oh, my God. That's the guy! Oh, I hate that guy."
没错。他们现在就在广播里听着你说话呢。他们坐在车后座，然后说：“天哪。就是那个人！哦，我讨厌那个人。”
I know. I hate that show, I can't even believe. We had a kid writing about how he thought he was too cool. He thought everybody, all his friends, were too cool. They were too cool to be, like, courteous. They were too cool to like things. They just wanted to be critical. And he said-- but secretly he didn't want to be like that. And he said, "And the way I'm going to start stopping to be like that is, I'm going to write this essay. Because it's not cool to do."
我知道。我讨厌那个节目，我简直不敢相信。我们有个孩子写他认为自己太酷了。他认为每个人，他所有的朋友，都太酷了。他们酷到不懂得礼貌。他们酷到不愿欣赏任何事物。他们只想保持批判性。他说——但私底下他并不想那样。他说：“我开始改变这种状态的方法，就是写这篇文章。因为那样做一点都不酷。”
NPR News is going to run its last This I Believe later this month. They run the series for four years, which is the same length as the original Murrow series.
NPR新闻本月晚些时候将播出最后一期“我信”。他们运营这个系列四年了，和最初的默罗系列时长一样。
A lot of the best This I Believes, a lot of the ones that I like the best, are actually This I Used to Believes. These are people basically talking about how they have changed and what's made them change. Like there's one by a nurse practitioner named Courtney Davis who talked about how early in her career, when patients would go through something really horrible and sad, she was one of those nurses who would try to keep things upbeat. She would keep her voice upbeat. And she would actually try to stay cheerful.
很多最好的“我信”文章，很多我最喜欢的，其实是“我曾经相信”。这些人基本上是在谈论他们是如何改变的，以及是什么让他们改变了。比如有一位名叫考特尼·戴维斯的执业护士写的一篇，她谈到在职业生涯早期，当病人经历非常可怕和悲伤的事情时，她是那种会尽量保持乐观的护士。她会保持语调欢快。她真的会努力表现得兴高采烈。
And even when her own mom, she writes in this essay, was dying in the hospital, she continued that way. Saying goodbye to her mom in that cheery nurse voice that she practiced her whole life.
甚至在她自己的母亲在医院弥留之际时，她依然保持这种方式。用她一生练习的那种欢快的护士语调与母亲告别。
I didn't know then that I could have climbed into bed and held her. That I should have wailed when she was gone. I no longer comfort others with false cheer.
那时我不知道我可以爬上床去拥抱她。我不知道在她离开时我应该放声大哭。我不再用虚假的欢快去安慰别人了。
So, I'm wondering you work in radio, and I work in radio. How come we haven't heard from you on what you believe? How come you haven't done an essay for us?
所以，我在想，你在做广播，我也在做广播。怎么我们还没听过你谈论你的信仰？你怎么没为我们写一篇作文？
Well, actually I mean it's funny. I think that I don't-- I say this and it's going to sound a little more dramatic than I mean it. But I'm not sure I believe anything, in that way, that would make for an essay.
其实，这很有趣。我想我不——我这么说听起来会比我的本意更戏剧化一些。但我并不确定我有什么信仰，那种可以写成一篇文章的信仰。
But did you ever, did you ever sit down-- or do you just sort of ask yourself rhetorically from time to time?
但是你有没有，你有没有坐下来——或者你只是时不时地反问一下自己？
I ask myself whenever I hear the series. I hear you on the radio and I think, how come I'm not on Jay's series? Like, how come I'm not doing This I Believe?
每次听到这个系列时我都会问自己。我在广播里听到你，我会想，为什么我不在杰伊的系列里？就像，为什么我不做一篇“我信”？
Are you sure you're not just giving up too easily though?
你确定你不是太轻易放弃了吗？
I don't know. I think I'm one of those people where like, I had a lot of really strong beliefs about stuff when I was a kid, and I like had a religious phase, and then I had a very strong, like, atheist phase and then I had a very political phase. And I was like politically correct for years. I mean the kind of politically correct where like, when I was in my 20s I went to Nicaragua and I called it Nikh-a-RAH-hua. And you know what I mean? Like, I was horrible. And--
我不知道。我想我是那种人，比如，我小时候对很多事情有非常强烈的信仰，我曾经历过宗教阶段，然后有一个非常强烈的无神论阶段，然后有一个非常政治化的阶段。我有好几年是那种政治正确的人。我的意思是那种政治正确，我在20多岁时去尼加拉瓜，我会把它读成“Nikh-a-RAH-hua”。你知道我的意思吗？就像，我那时很糟糕。而且——
Did you call it Nikh-a-Rah-hua on the radio, too?
你在广播里也把它读成“Nikh-a-Rah-hua”了吗？
Ah no. I knew better than that. At least I knew better than that. But you know I mean? Like, and then, just like, I got older and I saw that things seemed more complicated than the way that I'd believed them. And when I poll myself, I'm like, what do I believe in? Well I believe that listening to the radio in the car is the best place to listen to the radio. I've got that. But that doesn't seem like it's worthy of your series. I think it's true. I can defend it, but--.
啊没有。我知道那个不该那样读。至少我知道那个。但你知道我的意思吗？就像，后来，随着年龄增长，我发现事情似乎比我曾经相信的方式要复杂得多。当我审视自己时，我会想，我信仰什么？好吧，我相信在车里听广播是听广播最好的地方。我有这个。但这看起来似乎不配放入你的系列。我想这是真的。我可以为它辩护，但是——。
How about if something bad happened? Is there something you'd cling to?
如果发生了什么糟糕的事情呢？有什么是你愿意坚持的吗？
You mean in terms of a belief?
你是说关于信仰方面？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
I mean, I take comfort in the thought that when things seem really sad it's a comfort to me that well, everybody's going to go through this. Everybody's gone through this. And the problem is that, like, it's too much of a set of truisms to actually be good enough for your series.
我的意思是，我在这个想法中寻找慰藉：当事情看起来非常悲伤时，让我感到安慰的是，好吧，每个人都会经历这个。每个人都经历过这个。问题在于，它太像是一套陈词滥调了，不足以成为你系列里的好文章。
But your show is always looking for a conflict, and something to happen, and for something to change. I mean, maybe even this show is going to be about how something changes. So, possibly you're not interested in things that are static and enduring.
但你的节目总是在寻找冲突，寻找事情发生，寻找事情变化。我的意思是，也许连这个节目也会是关于某种事物的变化。所以，你可能对静态和永恒的事物不感兴趣。
No, I think that's true. It's funny like I think that's why I like This I Used to Believe. I'm much more attracted to that than to This I Believe because it just has the feeling of like, people are changing. And for me, drama is more interesting than ideas in a way. It's funny, I didn't even know I thought that until now I'm saying, that but I think it's true.
不，我想那是真的。很有趣，我想这就是为什么我喜欢“我曾经相信”。比起“我信”，我被前者吸引得多，因为它有一种感觉，就像人们在改变。对我来说，戏剧性在某种程度上比思想更有趣。这很有趣，我直到现在说出来才知道自己这么想，但我认为这是真的。
Maybe you believe in that.
也许你信仰那个。
And there's my essay. You are the master.
这就是我的文章了。你是大师。
I'm just an editor, man.
我只是个编辑，伙计。
Well, today on our program as I said before, This I Used to Believe . Our show today in four acts.
好吧，正如我之前所说，今天我们节目的主题是“我曾经相信”。今天的节目分为四幕。
Act One. Scrambled Nest Egg. About a kid, his parents, and their constant companion. Yes, the US economy.
第一幕：破碎的养老金。关于一个孩子、他的父母以及他们стоян伴侣。是的，美国经济。
Act Two. Team Spirit in the Sky. A Texas football coach gets called out on an unusual mission.
第二幕：天空中的团队精神。德克萨斯州的一位橄榄球教练接到了一项不同寻常的任务。
Act Three. Me Thinks Thou Doth Protest Too Much. In this case, the me of Me  thinks is a teenage girl. And the one doing the protesting is her mom.
第三幕：我以为你抗议得太过分了。在这种情况下，这个“我”指的是一个十几岁的女孩。而那个进行抗议的是她的妈妈。
Act Four. Pants Pants Revelation. In which we ask the question-- Can two people destroy their chances at love with one pair of pants?
第四幕：裤子的启示。我们要在其中提出一个问题——两个人能因为一条裤子而毁掉他们的爱情机会吗？
Stay with us.
请留下来。
Act One. Scrambled Nest Egg.
第一幕：破碎的养老金。
Sometimes you don't even realize you believe something until circumstances change in a way that destroys that belief. Alex French went to visit his parents in Massachusetts for a couple days last month.
有时你甚至意识不到自己相信什么，直到情况发生变化并摧毁了那种信念。亚历克斯·弗伦奇上个月去马萨诸塞州探望了他的父母几天。
We'll go to Cumberland Farms. We're going to buy some lottery tickets. Big jackpot tonight.
我们要去坎伯兰农场。我们要买些彩票。今晚有巨额头奖。
How much?
多少钱？
Oh, over two hundred million. It's sort of a cheap way of buying a dream.
哦，超过两亿。这算是一种廉价购买梦想的方式。
The French family bailout?
弗伦奇一家的救市计划？
Yeah, exactly the French family stimulus. So--.
是的，正是弗伦奇一家的刺激计划。所以——。
One afternoon in early January my mother called me in the middle of the day. I was just laid off, she told me. I could tell she was on her cellphone calling from the car. For the past nine years she'd worked behind the counter of an upscale jewelry store in a mall about 20 minutes outside of Boston.
一月初的一天下午，我母亲在中午给我打了电话。她说，她刚被解雇了。我听得出她是在车里用手机打的。过去九年，她在波士顿郊外约20分钟车程的一家购物中心的高档珠宝店柜台后工作。
All of the sudden, the recession was very, very real. Still, I could hear in her voice that she was relieved. She'd never admit it, but she hated her job. So long as your father keeps his job, she reassured me, we're going to be just fine.
突然之间，经济衰退变得非常、非常真实。尽管如此，我从她的声音里听出她感到释然。她永远不会承认，但她讨厌那份工作。她安慰我说，只要你父亲保住他的工作，我们就会过得很好。
Less than an hour later my phone rang again. It was my mother. She took a deep breath and then spoke. Your father has just been laid off, too.
不到一小时后，我的电话又响了。是我母亲。她深吸了一口气，然后说道：“你父亲也刚被解雇了。”
Sometimes when I think about it, it seems like something of biblical proportions. It's like, it's crazy. I don't know that much about the Bible, but I think there was somebody who had boils, and pestilence, and all kinds of things.
有时当我想到这一点，它似乎具有某种圣经般的规模。这太疯狂了。我对圣经了解不多，但我想曾经有人长了疖子、瘟疫，以及各种各样的事情。
What are you talking about?
你在说什么？
Talking about how I feel some days. That everything just happened at once. It was like anything bad that could happen to me or anybody I knew happened. So.
谈论我有时感觉如何。好像一切都同时发生了。就好像所有可能发生在我或我认识的任何人身上的坏事都发生了。所以。
I used to believe that recessions only affected people in faraway places like Detroit, Sacramento. I used to believe that my father would work until the day he turned 65 and then stop. There'd be some sort of retirement party and then the next day my parents would move to Clearwater, Florida. Where Dad would play golf and Mom would power walk.
我曾经相信经济衰退只会影响到底特律、萨克拉门托那些遥远地方的人。我曾经相信我父亲会一直工作到他65岁的那一天，然后停止。会有一个退休派对，然后第二天我父母就会搬到佛罗里达州的克利尔沃特。爸爸会在那里打高尔夫球，妈妈会快步走。
I never imagined that they could be so vulnerable. I never thought I might have to support my parents. It was inconceivable that they might someday have to move in with me because they could no longer pay their mortgage. All that changed when my mom called.
我从没想过他们会如此脆弱。我从没想过我可能不得不供养我的父母。他们有一天可能因为付不起抵押贷款而不得不搬来和我住，这简直是不可想象的。这一切都在我妈妈打来那个电话时改变了。
My parents were both 59 years old and for 30 years they've done everything right. Saved money and paid the mortgage on time. When I went back to check on them, everything looked the same. They still have their house and their cars, but there's a sense of danger looming. A sense that if this thing goes on for much longer, my parents' lives might change drastically.
我父母都59岁了，30年来他们一直做得很好。存钱，按时支付抵押贷款。当我回去看他们时，一切看起来都一样。他们还有房子和车子，但有一种危险正在逼近。一种感觉：如果这种情况再持续下去，我父母的生活可能会发生剧变。
You know, I talked to some people about actually going short term over to Iraq.
你知道，我确实和一些人谈过短期去伊拉克的事情。
My father has always worked as an engineer. Civil, environmental, hazardous materials, you name it. Tom French has done at all. Go to a mall in the Northeast and there's a pretty good chance that my father helped build it. And when the economy collapsed, the market for shopping centers and high rises went with it, along with my dad's job. I told myself during the train ride up there to stay positive. They'll be fine. You're going there for moral support. But when it came down to talking to my dad about going to Iraq, he ended up comforting me.
我父亲一直担任工程师。土木、环境、危险材料，随便什么。汤姆·弗伦奇都做过。去东北部的一个商场，很有可能我父亲参与了建造。当经济崩溃时，购物中心和高层建筑的市场随之消失，我父亲的工作也随之而去。去那里的火车上，我告诉自己要保持积极。他们会没事的。你是去提供精神支持的。但当真正和父亲谈起去伊拉克时，他反而安慰起我来了。
I've talked to some people who know people who've gone over there and done it. And it's not near as bad as you think it is.
我和一些人聊过，他们认识去过那边并且做过那些事的人。情况并没有你想象的那么糟。
Would you really consider doing that? I mean is it that bad that--?
你真的会考虑那样做吗？我的意思是情况糟糕到——？
Well, I don't want to go to work with a helmet and a bulletproof vest on, but I'd consider it.
嗯，我不想戴着头盔和防弹背心去工作，但我会考虑的。
Being laid off has affected both my parents so differently. My father, with his lifelong career, can't imagine doing anything but engineering. He'd go all the way to Iraq or even Afghanistan to keep doing it. But my mom, on the verge of 60, as worried as she is, also sees this as her chance. Anything seems possible. Massage therapy. TSA training. Jewelry making.
被解雇对我的父母产生了截然不同的影响。我父亲，带着他一生的职业生涯，无法想象除了工程外还能做什么。他会一直去到伊拉克甚至阿富汗去继续做这件事。但我妈妈，快60岁了，尽管她很担心，但也把这视为她的机会。什么看起来都有可能。按摩治疗。TSA培训。珠宝制作。
I'm considering maybe guidance counseling. The other thing I'm considering would be flower arranging. Which, since I love to garden, that's an option. And-- well, we're contemplating a children's book. And I'm hoping to work on a project about Versailles, and what I always want to see is what they don't take you to see. The rooms that have not been rehabilitated or refinished. And I would eventually like to go and take a look, and photograph it, and write about it.
我正在考虑也许做心理咨询。另一件我正在考虑的是插花。因为我喜欢园艺，所以那是个选择。而且——嗯，我们正在构思一本儿童读物。我希望做一个关于凡尔赛宫的项目，我一直想看的是他们不带你去看的地方。那些没有被修复或重装修的房间。我最终想去看看、拍些照片，并写写它们。
Growing up, my parents were never the types that needed to be parented. Our roles were well established. They were the parents. I was the kid. Even for this visit, for example, my father insisted that I make the short trip by train when I wanted to drive, but I didn't argue. Now that I'm here, for the first time in my life I feel like the roles are reversed. I wanted to weigh in on everything from Iraq to the dinner menu.
成长过程中，我父母从不是那种需要被当作孩子对待的人。我们的角色很明确。他们是父母。我是孩子。即使是这次探访，例如，我父亲坚持让我坐火车进行短途旅行，而我想开车，但我没争论。现在我在这儿，我人生中第一次感到角色颠倒了。我想对从伊拉克到晚餐菜单的一切发表意见。
Tom, do me a favor. Go on the other side and get me a container of goat cheese.
汤姆，帮我个忙。到那边给我拿一盒山羊奶酪。
OK.
好的。
Goat cheese?
山羊奶酪？
Yeah. Goat cheese.
是的。山羊奶酪。
Isn't that a little-- kind of a little bit of a luxury item for two unemployed folks?
那不是有点——对两个失业的人来说有点奢侈吗？
Yeah, but you know it lasts for a few weeks. It's OK. It sort of makes-- we don't eat out at all, so it makes staying in pleasurable. And so, buying a $4.50 container of something is a lot cheaper than going out and buying and having an $8.00 salad.
是，但你知道它能放几个星期。没事的。它某种程度上让——我们根本不出去吃饭，所以它让留在家里的生活变得愉快。所以，买一盒4.50美元的东西比出去花8美元买沙拉要便宜得多。
What do you feel like eating this week?
这周你想吃什么？
Soup.
汤。
Soup. Gruel?
汤。稀饭？
Day-old bakery.
昨天的面包。
They're joking around, but the most shocking thing that I noticed during my visit was how little food there was in the house. Growing up, it was such a comfort, a feeling of plenty when you opened the refrigerator. Now, it's not quite like a bachelor pad refrigerator, with just an empty bottle of ketchup. But it's not far from that, either.
他们是在开玩笑，但我访问期间注意到的最令人震惊的事情是屋里的食物竟然那么少。成长过程中，当你打开冰箱时，那种食物充足的感觉是一种慰藉。现在，它不太像单身汉的冰箱，只有一瓶空的番茄酱。但离那也不远了。
Yeah. No seriously, though. I mean, we're still eating pretty good. But if this thing goes on for an extended period, we're going to have to cut back even more. If this thing goes like four months or something and we're really ripping into savings to do that we're-- it's going to get cut back even more than it is already.
是的。不，说真的。我的意思是，我们仍然吃得相当不错。但如果这件事持续很长一段时间，我们将不得不进一步削减开支。如果这件事持续个四个月什么的，我们真的在动用存款来应付的话，我们——我们的开支会比现在削减得更多。
My parents are handling this as well as they can. It's easy to see that the worry is getting the best of my father. He tells me he's having trouble sleeping. Lays there in the dark, staring at the ceiling 'til 1:00 AM or 2:00 AM, wondering how much longer he's going to be able to pay the bills. The unemployment benefits my parents receive barely cover expenses. Or when he and my mom are going to have to start digging into their savings.
我父母正在尽他们所能地处理这件事。很容易看出担忧正在折磨我父亲。他告诉我他睡眠有问题。躺在黑暗中，盯着天花板直到凌晨1点或2点，想着他还能付多久的账单。我父母领取的失业救济金几乎勉强够支付开支。或者当他和妈妈不得不开始动用他们的存款时。
You know we went to take a little one-hour seminar down at unemployment to talk about the benefits and about looking for jobs.
你知道我们去失业部门参加了一个一小时的研讨会，谈论福利和寻找工作的事情。
I mean is there part of you that feels like-- I mean if you did qualify for something like welfare or for food stamps, I mean, is that something that you would do? Or is there a part of you that feels like, no like I'm-- I mean do you have too much pride for that, or--?
我的意思是，你心里有没有那种感觉——如果你们真的有资格获得某种福利或食品券，那是你们会做的事情吗？或者你们心里觉得，不，我——你是说你们太骄傲了，不能那样做，还是——？
No I don't think so. I mean it's like the stimulus. I mean, anyway my attitude is, is with unemployment and the stimulus and all these other things. I mean, I paid a lot of money into the system over the years. And I'm sure there's a lot of people that've paid more in than I have who've never taken anything out. But I mean, I've paid a lot of money into this system for a lot of years so, I'm in a situation, I didn't do anything wrong. I'm in a situation where I need some of that back now to get me through a tough spot. And if I'm entitled to something by the law, then I'll take it. Why not?
不，我不这么认为。我的意思是，就像刺激计划一样。反正我的态度是，关于失业救济、刺激计划以及所有这些其他事情。我的意思是，我多年来向这个系统支付了大量的钱。我敢肯定有很多人支付的比我多，却从来没从里面取过什么。但我的意思是，我多年来向这个系统付了很多钱，所以我现在处于一种境地，我没做错任何事。我处于一种需要拿回其中一部分来帮我度过难关的境地。如果法律规定我有权获得某些东西，那我会接受的。为什么不呢？
When you say I didn't do anything wrong, what do you mean by that?
当你说明明我没做错任何事时，你是指什么？
I didn't do anything wrong. I went to work every day. I worked hard. I did a good job. Obeyed the law. I paid my taxes. I did everything I was supposed to do. I didn't do anything wrong. This is a painful process we're going through now, but it will be over.
我没做错任何事。我每天去上班。我努力工作。我做得很棒。遵守法律。我缴纳了税款。我做了我该做的一切。我没做错任何事。我们现在经历的是一个痛苦的过程，但这终将结束。
We decided we would tell people that we were retired. And when we go back to work, we'll tell them, well we didn't think retirement was so great, so we thought we could go back to work.
我们决定告诉别人我们退休了。等我们回去工作时，我们会说，嗯，我们觉得退休没那么好，所以我们想可以回去工作。
At this point, they  don't need me to step in and say anything. I should stay calm, offer support, shut up. I don't tell them that I'm also losing sleep worrying about them. All weekend it's hard to know what to pay for. I don't even try to step in and pay at the grocery store. But they let me take them out for dinner and two lunches, and I pick up some odds and ends for them at the Family Dollar. I buy their lottery tickets, too.
在这一点上，他们不需要我介入说什么。我应该保持冷静，提供支持，闭嘴。我没有告诉他们我也在为他们担心而失眠。整个周末都很难知道该为什么买单。我甚至没试图介入在杂货店买单。但他们让我带他们出去吃了顿晚餐和两顿午餐，我在家庭廉价商店给他们买了一些零碎的东西。我也给他们买了彩票。
Alex French in New York.
纽约的亚历克斯·弗伦奇。
[MUSIC - "WORRIED MAN" BY JOHNNY CASH]
[音乐 - 约翰尼·卡什的《WORRIED MAN》]
Act Two. Team Spirit in the Sky.
第二幕：天空中的团队精神。
Just before Christmas the coach of a high school football team in Texas did something that football coaches pretty much never do. He urged half the parents at his school one Friday night to root for the other team. And they did it. His school was a Christian high school called Grapevine Faith. The other team was made of juvenile offenders from the high school at a state penitentiary. Kids whose families never came out to games. Lots of people in these kids' lives had given up on them.
圣诞节前夕，德克萨斯州一所高中的橄榄球队教练做了一件橄榄球教练几乎从不做的事。那个周五晚上，他敦促学校里一半的家长为对方球队加油。他们真的做了。他的学校是一所名叫“葡萄藤信仰”的基督教高中。另一支球队由来自州立监狱高中的少年犯组成。那些孩子的家人从来没来看过比赛。这些孩子生命中很多人都已经放弃了他们。
But this one night, hundreds of parents and kids learned their names and rooted for them when they made their plays, and actually rooted against their own team. These kids from the penitentiary ran onto the field through a spirit line. You know that thing where there are two lines of fans? They had cheerleaders cheering for them. This clip is from a TV story done by the NBC affiliate in Dallas-Fort Worth.
但就在那个晚上，数百名家长和孩子记住了他们的名字，并在他们进球时为他们欢呼，甚至实际上为自己的球队喝倒彩。这些来自监狱的孩子穿过一条“精神线”跑进球场。你知道那种有两排球迷的东西吗？他们有啦啦队为他们加油。这段剪辑来自达拉斯-沃斯堡NBC分支机构的一篇电视报道。
I want you all to line up in line, they're making a spirit line. I like say, what cousin, what'd you say? Can you repeat that? When I ran through this like I felt like it was just like something like angels or something that's all I felt cause I was just running through as fast as I can I just feel the wind rushing my face.
我要你们所有人排成一行，他们正在制作一条精神线。我说，表亲，你说什么？你能重复一下吗？当我跑过这条线时，感觉就像是天使什么的，那就是我所有的感觉，因为我只是尽可能快地跑过去，我只是感觉到风掠过我的脸庞。
That feeling of being unleashed lasted throughout the game and so did the cheers.
那种被释放的感觉在整场比赛中一直持续，欢呼声也一样。
I remember when was making like a play, I made a tackle and people yelling my name, I'm like, I don't even know these people.
我记得当我在做动作时，我完成了一次拦截，人们大喊着我的名字，我想，我甚至不认识这些人。
This story became one of those things that people linked to all over the internet, talked about on discussion boards, that thousands of moms forwarded to thousands of grown kids all over this country. And it got lots of press. The coach from the Christian school was on ESPN and the 700 Club, and all kinds of radio and TV. The NFL Commissioner invited him to be his guest at the Super Bowl.
这个故事成了人们在互联网上到处链接、在讨论板上谈论的事情，成千上万的母亲转发给全国各地成千上万的成年子女的事情。它得到了很多媒体报道。那位基督教学校的教练上了ESPN、《700俱乐部》，以及各种广播和电视节目。NFL总裁邀请他作为超级碗的贵宾。
And on Christmas morning, a woman named Trisha Sebastian saw a link and read about it in Rick Reilly's ESPN column online. She was alone. Her family was on the other side of the country. She was in an apartment in New York filled with her own moving boxes, in the kind of mood where this just got to her.
在圣诞节早晨，一位名叫翠莎·塞巴斯蒂安的女士看到了一个链接，并在里克·赖利ESPN的在线专栏中读到了它。她当时孤身一人。她的家人在国家的那一头。她身处纽约的一间公寓里，到处是她自己的搬家箱，那种心情让她深受触动。
One of the details from the story that just really killed me was that when they go back to the school, they got to be shackled when they get into the bus.
故事中让我感到特别难受的一个细节是，当他们回到学校时，他们上车时必须戴上手铐。
That they had to go into handcuffs when they get on the bus.
他们上车时必须戴上手铐。
Handcuffs, when they get back into the bus.
手铐，当他们回到车上时。
And so she decided to write an email to the coach at this Christian school who organized this nice thing for these kids. A guy named Chris Hogan.
于是她决定给这位为这些孩子组织了这件好事的基督教学校的教练写一封电子邮件。一个叫克里斯·霍根的人。
And I said, Dear Mr. Chris Hogan. Thank you for being a good inspirational leader to your players and to your players' fans by encouraging them to think of those who are less fortunate than they. I'm a very lapsed Catholic, leaning towards agnosticism, who has seen too many people who claim to be Christians behaving in a very un-Christian way. You are one of those bright few who embody what being Christian means. And I'm glad that you're in a place where you can show young children an example of being a good Christian. Thank you.
我说，亲爱的克里斯·霍根先生。感谢您成为您球员和球员球迷的优秀励志领袖，鼓励他们去关怀那些比他们不幸的人。我是一个非常疏离的天主教徒，倾向于不可知论，见过太多声称是基督徒的人表现出非常不符合基督徒的行为。您是那少数几个真正体现基督徒意义的人之一。我很高兴您身处一个可以向年幼的孩子展示成为一名优秀基督徒榜样的地方。谢谢您。
Now there's a time stamp on that because it's an email. What time did you send that?
因为是邮件，所以有个时间戳。你是几点发的？
6:32 in the morning, on Christmas day.
圣诞节早晨6点32分。
And that afternoon, much to her wondering eyes did appear a reply, time stamped 12:09 PM.
那天下午，令她惊讶的是，她收到了回复，时间戳是中午12点09分。
So he wrote to me, and this is what he said, "Thank you so much for your kind words. Trisha, I've received literally hundreds of emails over the past few days. And yours is the first I've responded to. Yours reached out of my computer and gripped my heart. When I read it, my spirit was pressed to answer you first, when I'd read that you were leaning towards agnosticism because of the actions of Christians.
所以他写信给我，他是这样说的：“非常感谢您的美言。翠莎，在过去几天里我确实收到了数百封邮件。而您是第一个我回复的。您的邮件穿透了我的电脑，抓住了我的心。当我读到它时，我的精神迫使我先回答您，当我读到您因为基督徒的行为而倾向于不可知论时。”
"Let me encourage you to not make a judgment about God, based on the actions of men. My heart is heavy to think of you walking away from a God who loves you so much. Trisha, would you consider speaking, even if it's by email, about the idea of God? I do not think your sending me the email was coincidence. I expect to hear back from you, young lady. Thanks again for your exhortation. Bless you."
“让我鼓励您不要根据人类的行为来评判上帝。想到您远离一位如此深爱您的上帝，我的心沉重。翠莎，您会考虑谈论，即使是通过电子邮件，谈论关于上帝的想法吗？我不认为您给我发这封邮件是巧合。我期待您的回复，年轻女士。再次感谢您的劝诫。上帝保佑您。”
It's interesting that at the end he gets all-- right back to me young lady, like you're one of the kids in his program.
有趣的是，最后他变得——像对着我说话一样，年轻女士，就像你是他项目里的孩子之一。
Yeah, I know. Which I thought was kind of cute.
是的，我知道。我觉得那挺可爱的。
She wasn't really sure, though, if she wanted to hear his pitch about Christianity. But she thought that at least she owed him the courtesy of a reply. So she wrote back. Mainly to clarify that she hadn't become agnostic because she'd met hypocritical Christians. She didn't think so badly of Christians.
不过，她并不确定自己是否想听他关于基督教的推销。但她觉得至少她欠他一个回复的礼貌。于是她回信了。主要是为了澄清她不是因为遇到了虚伪的基督徒才变得不可知论的。她对基督徒并没有那么糟糕的看法。
She told him that she'd been raised Catholic and she really did used to believe in God. But she started questioning her faith three years ago, when a close friend of hers named Kelly, who was just 32, was diagnosed and very quickly died of colon cancer. Tricia wrote this long heartfelt email explaining all this, in which she politely declined the coach's offer and closed with quote, "Thank you again for being such a good man and a good Christian." And that was that.
她告诉他，她是天主教徒养大的，她确实曾经相信上帝。但三年前，当她一位名叫凯莉的好朋友——年仅32岁——被诊断出患有结肠癌并很快去世后，她开始质疑自己的信仰。翠莎写了一封漫长而真诚的电子邮件解释了这一切，并在信中礼貌地拒绝了教练的邀请，结尾引用了：“再次感谢您成为这样一个好人和好基督徒。”事情就是这样。
Until three weeks later, Coach Hogan wrote to her again. "I know we had finished our conversation," he said. And he'd been fine with that. But there was a snag. God kept waking him up in the middle of the night, putting her very sincere emails into his head.
直到三周后，霍根教练又给她写了信。“我知道我们已经结束了谈话，”他说。他对此并没有意见。但有个障碍。上帝一直在半夜叫醒他，把她那些非常真诚的邮件塞进他的脑子里。
"I have tried to ignore it for several weeks," he wrote. "But I need some sleep. In prayer this morning, I decided this isn't going away until I make contact with you. I know God has put something on my heart to tell you."
“我已经尝试忽略它好几周了，”他写道。“但我需要睡眠。今天早上的祈祷中，我决定在与您取得联系之前，这件事不会结束。我知道上帝把一些话放在我的心里要我告诉您。”
Trisha did not know what to do. ever since her friend died, her religious beliefs were set.
翠莎不知道该怎么办。自从她的朋友去世后，她的宗教信仰就定型了。
I'd pretty much thought like-- come to the conclusion that there's no God out there. Things happen. This thing happened, and is nothing special.
我想我已经得出了结论——觉得外面没有上帝。事情发生了。这件事发生了，没什么特别的。
And you didn't want to get into it.
你不想深入讨论它。
I didn't really-- didn't want to get into it. It's like part of what made life after Kelly's death a little more bearable was knowing that it just happened. That there was no reason why.
我真的——不想深入讨论。就像在凯莉去世后让生活变得更容易的一点就是知道这件事就是发生了。没有任何理由为什么。
And was part of it this guy saying to you, OK God has been talking to me about you and he's waking me up in the middle of the night, and was there part of you thinking like, oh no, like what if that's real? Like, what if this is actually the way that God is trying to get to me?
那有没有一部分是你觉得，好吧，这个家伙对你说，OK上帝一直在关于你跟我谈话，他半夜叫醒我，有没有一部分你觉得，噢不，如果那是真的怎么办？比如，如果这就是上帝试图触及我的方式怎么办？
Yeah, I mean like a lot of it's like, oh crap, what's he going to say? Here's this guy who is a stranger, who's telling me, "God has something to say to you." OK, you can sometimes ignore your friends, but like not this. This is kind of weird, you know?
是的，我的意思是很多时候就像，糟了，他会说什么？这是个陌生人，他在告诉我，“上帝有些话要对你说。”OK，你有时可以忽略你的朋友，但——不能忽略这个。这有点怪，你知道吗？
What was especially weird is that Coach Hogan was basically just this random guy from the news. Trisha said that it was like, as if Captain "Sully", who landed that US Air flight on the Hudson, suddenly called her up to say God told him to especially save her.
特别奇怪的是，霍根教练基本上只是新闻里的一个随机路人。翠莎说，这就像是那个在哈德逊河上降落美联航航班的“萨利”机长突然打电话给她，说上帝告诉他要特别拯救她。
And finally, Trisha decides that she's going to do it. And asked Coach Hogan if he would be willing to let her tape this conversation, and maybe play a little bit of it here on the radio. The coach feels that it's his mission to witness for God wherever he can. He sees his work in the high school as part of that. He teaches Sunday school. He talks about God with people all the time, he says. So he had no problem with that all. So, these two people with very different beliefs got on the phone together.
最后，翠莎决定她要这么做。她问霍根教练是否愿意让她录下这段对话，并可能在广播里播放一点点。教练觉得他的使命是在他能做到的任何地方为上帝作见证。他把他在高中的工作视为其中的一部分。他教主日学。他说他一直在和人们谈论上帝。所以他完全没有问题。于是，这两个信仰迥异的人通了电话。
This is Chris Hogan.
我是克里斯·霍根。
Chris Hi! This is Trisha, how do you doing?
克里斯，你好！我是翠莎，你好吗？
Hey Trisha how are you?
嘿翠莎，你好吗？
I'm OK. So, the reason why I really wanted to talk to you is because you had mentioned that God was speaking to you and telling you that you needed to talk to me. I'm just wondering what you think God's message to me right now is.
我很好。所以，我真的很想和你谈谈的原因是，因为你提到上帝在跟你说话，告诉你需要跟我谈谈。我只是想知道你觉得上帝现在给我的信息是什么。
OK. Well, it's interesting because your email, as soon as I read it, my gut just turned over and I could just feel pressed in my spirit. And later that night, in the middle of the night, I had this really strange dream. And I woke up and there was your email in my head, and I thought well, that's strange. So I go back to sleep and it happens about three hours later. He continued to wake me up and what's interesting? He kept waking me up at the exact same time.
OK。好吧，这很有趣，因为您的邮件，我一读到它，我的内心就翻江倒海，我可以感觉到我的精神受到了冲击。那天晚上晚些时候，我做了一个非常奇怪的梦。我醒来，您的邮件就在我的脑海里，我想，好吧，那很奇怪。所以我回去睡觉，大约三小时后又发生了。他继续叫醒我，有趣的是什么？他一直在我完全相同的时间叫醒我。
Wait, what time?
等等，几点？
He kept waking me up every single night at 1:30. Every single night. And the interesting thing is when I would ignore it, he'd wake me up again at 4:04 in the morning.
他每晚都准时在凌晨1:30叫醒我。每晚都这样。有趣的是，当我忽略它时，他会在凌晨4:04再次叫醒我。
OK that's kind of weird because for the last couple of weeks, I've been waking up at 3:00 in the morning for no reason at all.
OK，那有点奇怪，因为过去几周，我一直莫名其妙地在凌晨3点醒来。
Yeah. It's interesting because the longer I prayed about it, I felt like that he was trying to get me to tell you that everybody has faith in something. And if you don't have faith in like the biblical idea of God, then you must have faith in something else that you think, well then this is true. And I think my spirit is just telling me to tell you, don't settle for that.
是的。很有趣，因为我为这件事祈祷得越久，我就越觉得他是想让我告诉你，每个人都对某事有信仰。如果你没有那种圣经中上帝的信仰，那你一定对别的什么有信仰，你认为，好吧，这是真的。我想我的精神只是在告诉我告诉你，不要满足于那个。
For the next hour, Coach Hogan tried to convince Trisha that God exists using all kinds of arguments. The first and second laws of thermodynamics. And arguing against the Big Bang, and evolution. It was the kind of conversation that led, sort of inevitably, to questions like why does God give us free will to believe in him or not? Or this snippet  will capture some of the tone of things for you. They're talking about whether the Bible is right when it says that some things are objectively good, and some things are objectively true, and other things are objectively evil. Some things are just wrong.
在接下来的一个小时里，霍根教练试图通过各种论点让翠莎相信上帝的存在。热力学第一和第二定律。反对大爆炸论和进化论。这种对话不可避免地引向了一些问题，比如为什么上帝给我们自由意志去相信他与否？这段片段会让你捕捉到一些谈话的基调。他们正在谈论圣经是否正确，当它说有些事情在客观上是好的，有些事情在客观上是真的，还有些事情在客观上是邪恶的。有些事情就是错误的。
If you say good is only people's opinion. It stems from our own-- you define true for you and I define true for me, then how do you reconcile that with Hitler saying it is true that if we can eliminate Jews and other people on the planet that it'll be a better planet because we're a superior race. And of course he gets his worldview from Charles Darwin.
如果你说好只是人们的观点。它源于我们自己的——你定义对你来说是真的，我定义对我来说是真的，那么你如何与希特勒说的话相协调呢？他说如果能消灭犹太人和地球上的其他人，那将是一个更好的星球，因为我们是优等种族。当然，他的世界观来自查尔斯·达尔文。
Right, wait. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
对，等等。等等，等等，等等，等等。
So if Mother Teresa gets to choose good and Hitler gets to choose good, who's right?
所以如果特蕾莎修女可以选择什么是好，而希特勒也可以选择什么是好，那谁是对的？
I'm sitting here listening to you. Up until you brought out Hitler I was completely with you all the way, and all of a sudden you're throwing Hitler out, and I'm all-- and I'm thinking to myself, where is he going with this? How can I--
我坐在这里听你说话。在你扯出希特勒之前，我完全赞同你，而突然之间你抛出了希特勒，我完全——我在想，他这是要干什么？我怎么能——
Well, and you know how I brought Hitler out? I'm just using your logic.
好吧，你知道我怎么引出希特勒的吗？我只是在用你的逻辑。
Yeah, but did you have to go all the way out there?
是的，但你一定要扯那么远吗？
And I'm trying to demonstrate that what you're saying doesn't work. When you take it to its logical conclusion, what you're saying doesn't work.
我只是在试图证明你所说的是行不通的。当你把它推向逻辑结论时，你所说的是行不通的。
When Trisha tries to talk about her friend Kelly, and how her faith changed when Kelly got cancer, Coach Hogan tells her about his Aunt Gina, who had faith. And when she got cervical cancer, it miraculously went away.
当翠莎试图谈论她的朋友凯莉，以及凯莉得了癌症后她的信仰是如何改变时，霍根教练告诉她关于他姑姑吉娜的事，她有信仰。当她得了宫颈癌时，它奇迹般地消失了。
Somehow, a lady who was "over 90% dead", quote unquote, now has not one ounce of cancer.
不知怎么的，一位“90%以上已死”的女士，现在竟然一点癌症都没有了。
OK, so my question is why did your aunt survive and my friend die?
OK，所以我的问题是为什么你姑姑活下来了而我的朋友却死了？
OK. Now let me tell you this, Trisha. Do not, for an instance, believe anybody who can tell you why that is. Including me, any pastor, any priest, anybody, because that is an area designed for God.
OK。现在让我告诉你这个，翠莎。千万，千万不要相信任何能告诉你为什么会这样的人。包括我，任何牧师，任何神父，任何人都不要信，因为那是一个上帝设计的领域。
But there were a lot of things that, when we found out that Kelly had cancer, I prayed. I prayed so hard. I prayed for-- I prayed like I've never prayed before. Because I was taught growing up, that if you prayed to God, God would answer your prayers.
但是有很多事情，当我们发现凯莉得了癌症时，我祈祷了。我祈祷得非常努力。我为——我像以前从未祈祷过那样祈祷。因为我在成长过程中被教导说，如果你向上帝祈祷，上帝就会回答你的祈祷。
Did you know that's false? Let me give you a for instance. Suppose I prayed today to win the lottery. He might not answer that prayer, and it might be for my own good. He is God. He knows everything, he's all powerful, he's all good, he's all knowing, he's omniscient. Obviously, he's superior to some Texas high school football coach, right?
你知道那是错的吗？让我给你举个例子。假设我今天祈祷中彩票。他可能不会回答那个祈祷，而且这可能是为了我自己的好处。他是上帝。他无所不知，他全能，他全善，他全知。显然，他比某个德克萨斯州的高中橄榄球教练要优越，对吧？
When they finally do get off the phone, they're both friendly. But they both also seem a little disappointed. Trisha and I sit down to talk about how she thinks it went.
当他们最终挂断电话时，他们都表现得很友好。但他们似乎也都有些失望。翠莎和我坐下来谈论她觉得谈话进行得如何。
It was totally not what I expected. I was thinking, OK, here is my chance to speak to a man who really believes in God and find out the answers to these burning questions I have. You know, I've been struggling with this grief that I feel over my friend's death. And I thought that he would be able to counsel me and console me. And what happened instead was he basically brought out argument after argument, like he was saying that the theory of evolution is contradicted by a seventh grader's text book, and just--
这完全不是我预期的。我在想，OK，这是我与一个真正信仰上帝的人交谈并找到我心中那些灼热问题的答案的机会。你知道，我一直在这个对朋友死亡的悲伤中挣扎。我以为他能够开导我、安慰我。结果他却基本上抛出一个接一个的论点，比如他说进化论被七年级的教科书反驳了，只是——
Oh, I see. He was trying to argue with you about the existence of God instead of trying to comfort you.
噢，我明白了。他是在试图和你争论上帝是否存在，而不是试图安慰你。
Yeah. I think that was it. There were times when I'd completely warmed up to him, and then he says stuff like what he said earlier about how Hitler and truth-- One of the jokes that a lot of my friends have is that the minute you pull Hitler out in any argument, you automatically lose. And that completely turned me off towards him. And now I'm still left with all these questions.
是的。我想就是那样。有些时候我完全对他心软了，然后他又说出像之前关于希特勒和真理的那种话。很多朋友开的一个玩笑是，只要你在任何争论中抛出希特勒，你就自动输了。这完全让我对他倒了胃口。现在我还剩下所有这些问题。
Is there any small part of you that thought he might be able to put the religious message in some way that would finally make sense to you? Like he would say  to you--
你内心是否有哪怕一小部分认为他可能以某种方式提出宗教信息，最终会让你觉得有道理？比如他会跟你说——
I was-- yeah.
我是——是的。
You did hope that?
你确实希望那样？
I really did hope that. Deep down, and I've said this to so many friends of mine, I really want to believe again.
我真的希望。在内心深处，我已经对我很多朋友说过这一点，我真的想再次相信。
So you did want him to bring you back to God?
所以你确实希望他带你回到上帝身边？
Maybe. Possibly. Most likely.
也许。可能。极有可能。
But just the way he was doing it wasn't a way that really talked to you?
但只是他那样做的方式并不是真正触动你的方式？
No. no.
不是。不是。
I wonder if the problem with that was just the way he was going about it and the arguments he was using. Or I wonder if really there's nothing anybody could actually say to make you believe this thing that now you find yourself not believing?
我想知道问题是不是仅仅在于他处理它的方式和他使用的论点。还是说我想知道，真的没有人能真正说出什么来让你相信这个你现在发现自己不相信的东西？
I don't know. If someone were to just tell me, this is why Kelly died and they were able to relate it back to God, I would probably respond to that better.
我不知道。如果有人能直接告诉我，这就是为什么凯莉会死，并且他们能够把它与上帝联系起来，我可能会对那个反应更好一些。
And then when you asked him this, what did he say?
那么当你问他这个时，他说了什么？
We never got to that point. We never got to that point. I couldn't get him there. I couldn't ask him the questions I really wanted to ask.
我们从未走到那一步。我们从未走到那一步。我无法让他到那。我无法问他我真正想问的问题。
But what if it's as simple as, for people who believe in God, God takes different people at different times. And that doesn't mean that God doesn't have some plan for you, you know?
但如果简单点呢，对于信仰上帝的人来说，上帝在不同时间带走不同的人。这并不意味着上帝对你没有任何计划，你知道吗？
See that makes more sense to me than anything he ever said in our conversation.
看，比起他在谈话中说的任何话，这对我来说更合理。
Well that's very sad, because I actually don't believe in God.
好吧，那很令人难过，因为我其实并不相信上帝。
Because her main question wasn't really discussed very much in that first conversation, she set up another call with Coach Hogan. And she asked him if this time I could get on the line with them, mainly just be sure that everything stayed focused and she got the actual answers that she wanted. Again, the coach was fine with that.
因为她的主要问题在第一次谈话中并没有得到太多讨论，她安排了与霍根教练的另一次通话。她问他这次我是否可以上线，主要是为了确保一切保持焦点，她得到了她想要的实际答案。教练依然表示没问题。
So the reason why we're calling is because after you talked to Trisha last time, Trisha said to me that the main thing she felt like she wanted an answer to, somehow it didn't really come up. And really it comes down to her friend Kelly.
所以我们打电话的原因是，在你上次和翠莎谈过之后，翠莎对我说，她觉得她想要答案的主要事情，不知怎么地并没有真正提出来。而且实际上归结为她的朋友凯莉。
Sure.
当然。
It doesn't make any sense for someone like me to still be here when someone like Kelly, who was such a good person and who spread so much good throughout the world in her small, own little way. It just doesn't make sense.
对于像我这样的人来说，当像凯莉这样的人——一个如此善良、以她自己的小方式向世界传播了那么多美好的人——依然存在，却没什么意义。这真的没道理。
Sure. This is the most common question that folks who are anti-God ask. I don't know if you guys know that or not, but this is the most common objection to God. Why does God allow bad things to happen to good people? You have to understand that sin entered the world through one person, Adam. Now, if you read what the Bible says happened as a result of sin, every single person who's ever been born is born into sin. Do you understand the Garden of Eden and the condition we have now are two different scenarios. One was pre-sin, one is because of sin.
当然。这是那些反上帝的人问的最常见的问题。我不知道你们是否知道，但这这是对上帝最常见的反驳。为什么上帝允许坏事发生在好人身上？你必须明白罪是通过一个人进入世界的，亚当。现在，如果你读圣经中记载的罪的结果，每一个出生的人都是生而有罪的。你理解伊甸园和我们现在的状况是两种不同的情况吗？一个是罪之前，一个是由于罪。
So I'm sorry to break this into a blunt way. So you're saying that cancer is caused by sin?
所以很抱歉用这种直率的方式打断你。你是说癌症是由罪引起的吗？
I'm saying anything on this Earth-- all the diseases, all the bad things that are here-- are a result of sin. That's what the Bible teaches. Your friend Kelly, I'm not saying that she sinned to get cancer, I'm saying we're in a fallen world.
我是说地球上的任何事物——所有的疾病，所有这里的坏事——都是罪的结果。这就是圣经所教导的。你的朋友凯莉，我并不是说她犯罪才得了癌症，我是说我们身处一个堕落的世界。
All through Trisha's conversations with the coach, I felt like I was hearing over and over why it is so hard for religious and nonreligious people to communicate sometimes. The premises are just so far from each other. When the coach says we live in a fallen world, that explanation is a comfort to him. It's comforting to think that he doesn't have to make sense about every injustice and every terrible thing that happens on this Earth. It's messy on this Earth. Things will be better in heaven. But because God understands the details of why one person with cancer lives and another person with cancer dies, he doesn't have to. And the coach has a hard time, I think, seeing why this explanation isn't a comfort to Trisha. As soon as he understood that what Trisha wanted was an explanation for Kelly's death that would help her feel better about that death, this is what he said to her.
在翠莎与教练的整个对话中，我感觉我反复听到为什么宗教和非宗教人士有时如此难以交流。前提实在相差太远了。当教练说我们生活在一个堕落的世界时，这种解释对他来说是一种慰藉。认为他不必为地球上发生的每一件不公正和每一件可怕的事情寻找意义，这很让人宽慰。地球上是一团糟。天堂里会更好。但因为上帝理解为什么一个患癌症的人活着而另一个人患癌症死亡的细节，他不必理解。而且我想，教练很难看出为什么这种解释对翠莎不是一种安慰。当他明白翠莎想要的是一个关于凯莉死亡的解释，能帮助她对死亡感觉好一点时，这是他对比她说的。
Well I can tell you this. Your friend Kelly, Trisha, didn't do anything necessarily to deserve that. I'm not saying that in the least. But I am saying she lives in a fallen world.
好吧，我可以告诉你这个。你的朋友凯莉，翠莎，并没有做什么一定应得那个的事情。我一点也没这么说。但我确实在说她生活在一个堕落的世界里。
Well I think we all do.
好吧，我想我们都是。
There's no question. There's a fallen world. And the world has fallen, because people have chosen evil. And so, as a result, sin entered the world, and with sin comes a lot of things. And they're going to affect people. But the great thing is, this is not where eternity rests.
毫无疑问。有一个堕落的世界。世界已经堕落了，因为人们选择了邪恶。因此，结果是，罪进入了世界，随着罪而来的是很多事情。它们会影响人们。但伟大之处在于，这不是永恒存在的地方。
Trisha is that helpful to you?
翠莎，那对你有帮助吗？
A little bit. I'm getting an answer. And it's the answer that he agrees and believes in. But it's-- I don't think I'm there yet.
有一点。我得到了一些答案。那是他同意并相信的答案。但它是——我不认为我还没到那一步。
Coach Hogan told us that he was going to feel really sad when he got off this phone call. But in the weeks that have followed, he has accomplished this-- Trisha has been thinking about God a lot more, she says. She doesn't really believe just yet, but she says she's open to it.
霍根教练告诉我们，他挂掉这个电话时会感到非常难过。但在随后的几周里，他达成了这一点——翠莎说她开始更多地思考上帝了。她还不是真的相信，但她说她对此持开放态度。
Coming up. What happens when you learn that the thing that you believe is the source of your personal power and magnetism is pretty much the opposite. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来。当你了解到你认为是你的个人力量和吸引力来源的东西，实际上恰恰相反时，会发生什么？这稍后会有。来自芝加哥公共广播和国际公共电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week in our program, of course, we choose theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's Show-- This I Used I Believe. We have stories today about people doing that all too uncommon thing of reexamining their beliefs and coming to new conclusions.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题并为您带来关于该主题的不同种类的故事。今天的节目——“我曾经相信”。我们今天的故事讲述的是人们做着那件太不常见的事情：重新审视他们的信念并得出新的结论。
We've arrived at Act Three of our show.
我们到达了节目的第三幕。
Act Three. Methinks the lady doth protest too much.
第三幕：我以为那女士抗议得太过分了。
You know, parents have an advantage over their children when it comes to inculcating them with a set of beliefs. With their set of beliefs. Let's be honest.
你知道，当涉及到向孩子灌输一套信念时，父母比孩子有优势。用他们的一套信念。说实话。
They're taller, first of all. And they're adults, capable of argument. Persuasive argument, hopefully. But if none of that works, they also control allowances, weekends, basically everything in the kid's life.
首先，他们更高。而且他们是成年人，有能力争论。有说服力的争论，希望如此。但如果这些都没用，他们还控制零花钱、周末，基本上控制着孩子生活中的一切。
Molly Antopol was 13 when she confronted the full strength of this power imbalance.
莫莉·安托波尔13岁时面临了这种权力失衡的全部力量。
When I was in seventh grade, my social studies teacher led our class in a rousing debate over Roe v. Wade. I had never heard of abortion. I barely knew what sex was. And my immediate emotional reaction, and the position I backed enthusiastically in the debate, was that it seemed to me like murder.
当我上七年级时，我的社会学老师带领我们班围绕“罗诉韦德案”展开了一场激烈的辩论。我以前从未听说过堕胎。我几乎不知道性是什么。而我即时的情绪反应，以及我在辩论中热情支持的立场，就是在我看来那就像谋杀。
That night over dinner, when my mother asked what I'd done in school I told her about the class discussion, and about my stirring defense of the pro-life position. My mother, a longtime liberal and women's rights advocate, had never looked so crushed.
那天晚餐时，当妈妈问我学校做了什么时，我告诉了她班级讨论的事，以及我那激昂的维护反堕胎立场的内容。我妈妈，一位长期的自由主义者和女性权利倡导者，从未看起来如此崩溃。
"Murder?", she said.
“谋杀？”，她说。
And when I said yes, she repeated it again and again like a mantra. Then she set down her fork and stared at me, as if really noticing her daughter for the first time. "You're saying a woman shouldn't be allowed to decide what she does with her own body? With her own fetus?"
当我说是时，她一遍又一遍地重复，像个咒语。然后她放下叉子，盯着我，仿佛第一次真正注意到她的女儿。“你是说不应该允许一个女人决定她对自己身体做什么？对自己体内的胎儿做什么？”
"Exactly," I said. I had no clue what a fetus was.
“正是，”我说。我根本不知道胎儿是什么。
"And you're saying that if a woman's raped, or molested, or whatever she shouldn't have the right to terminate the pregnancy?"
“你是说如果一个女人被强奸，或骚扰，或无论怎样，她不应该有权终止怀孕？”
As my mother continued to lecture, she wouldn't even look at me. She seemed to be staring straight past me at some indeterminate blank spot on the wall. And I truly understood, for the first time, what it meant to disappoint her. I swallowed a pain in my throat, but it came back up again. And finally she stood up and dumped her dishes in the sink. Then she faced me and said, "Go to Siberia for half an hour and think about what you just said."
随着我妈妈继续讲课，她甚至不看我。她似乎直直地盯着我，看着墙上某个不确定的空白处。我第一次真正明白了让她失望意味着什么。我咽下了喉咙里的痛苦，但它又涌上来了。最后她站起来，把碗盘倒进水槽。然后她面对我说：“去西伯利亚待半小时，想想你刚才说了什么。”
"Siberia" was my bedroom closet. It was where I was sent for timeouts when my mother thought I needed to think things over. My mother was not the type to respectfully agree to disagree. She came from a long, steady line of organizers, who broke the law in an effort to change minds, starting with her great-grandparents, Trotskyites in Ukraine.
“西伯利亚”是我的卧室衣柜。每当妈妈觉得我需要反省时，我就会被关禁闭在那里。我妈妈不是那种尊重地同意分歧的人。她来自一长串稳定的组织者，他们为了改变想法而触犯法律，从她的曾祖父母开始，乌克兰的托洛茨基分子。
That night in Siberia, squeezed between coats and old board games and camping gear, I did think about abortion. And it still seemed to me like murder. But I knew my mother would never let this go. And I knew it was up to to me to end it for both of us.
那天晚上在西伯利亚，挤在外套、旧桌游和野营装备之间，我确实思考了堕胎。对我来说它看起来仍然像是谋杀。但我知道妈妈永远不会放过这件事。我知道结束这一切得靠我。
If I let her win, I could crawl up on the sofa and watch Kristi Yamaguchi skate in the Olympics. That was all I wanted to do that winter. But when I returned to the kitchen, my mother was replacing the Indian takeout menu on the refrigerator with a bumper sticker that read, "Keep your rosaries off my ovaries."
如果我让她赢，我就能爬上沙发，看着克里斯蒂·山口在奥运会上滑冰。那年冬天我只想做那个。但当我回到厨房时，妈妈正在把冰箱上的印度外卖菜单换成一张保险杠贴纸，上面写着：“让你的念珠远离我的卵巢。”
"What are rosaries?," I said.
“什么是念珠？”，我说。
"Christian prayer beads," she said.
“基督教祈祷珠，”她说。
"What are ovaries?"
“什么是卵巢？”
"The part of a woman's body that makes eggs."
“女人身体里制造卵子的部分。”
"Why would someone put rosaries on their ovaries?"
“为什么有人会把念珠放在卵巢上？”
"It's a metaphor," she said. "For Christian fundamentalists who try to force their views on other people."
“这是一个隐喻，”她说。“针对那些试图将自己的观点强加于人的基督教原教旨主义者。”
"Like you are?," I said. I spent the next half hour back in Siberia.
“像你一样？”，我说。接下来的半小时我又回到了西伯利亚。
[MUSIC - "QUE SERA SERA" ON SITAR]
[音乐 - 西塔琴版的《QUE SERA SERA》]
And so the re-education began. Over the course of that winter my mother made me wear buttons to school-- "No Mandatory Motherhood. Pro-child. Pro-choice." which I removed and slipped into my backpack as I walked into class. She pulled feminist paperbacks off our cinder block and plywood shelves, and read from them aloud.
于是再教育开始了。那年冬天，妈妈让我戴着徽章去学校——“不强制母性。支持孩子。支持选择。”我走进教室时就把它们摘下来塞进背包里。她从我们的煤渣砖和胶合板书架上抽出女权主义平装书，大声读出来。
My mother even took me across town one early February morning where we, along with other members of her women's group, helped escort pregnant women into an abortion clinic. Together, we marched toward pro-life protesters who sat outside the building in lawn chairs clutching their own signs, one depicting a baby that looked more alien than human. Tiny and shriveled and blue.
妈妈甚至在二月初的一个早晨带我穿过整个城市，在那里，我们和她妇女团体的其他成员一起，帮助护送孕妇进入堕胎诊所。我们一起走向坐在建筑物外草坪椅上拿着自己标语的反对堕胎抗议者，其中一张标语描绘了一个看起来比人类更像外星人的婴儿。小小的、皱巴巴的、蓝色的。
"I hate that sign," my mother said quietly. I looked at my mother and she looked back. At that moment she seemed more tired than anything else and I wanted to cut her a break.
“我讨厌那个标语，”妈妈低声说。我看着妈妈，她也看着我。在那一刻她看起来比什么都累，我想给她一个喘息的机会。
"You were right," I blurted. She stopped walking.
“你是对的，”我脱口而出。她停止了行走。
"Right about what?"
“关于什么对？”
"About abortion," I said. "About everything, OK?"
“关于堕胎，”我说。“关于一切，行吗？”
"Say it then."
“那你说出来。”
"Abortion should be safe and legal," I said. I could tell she didn't believe me.
“堕胎应该是安全合法的，”我说。我看得出她不相信我。
"Say it again," she said. And I did.
“再说一遍，”她说。我照做了。
I had hoped that by giving in, things would return to normal. And they did for a few days. My mother went to work. I went to school. And in the evenings, we sat up late eating takeout and watching recaps of the Olympics.
我希望通过让步，事情会恢复正常。确实有几天是这样。妈妈去上班。我去学校。晚上，我们坐得很晚吃外卖，看奥运会的回顾。
Then came my birthday. For months I'd been begging for a pair of Riedell figure skates. I pictured myself impressing the skinny, dark-haired guy behind the snack stand at the ice rink with my triple salchows. I'd pointed the skates out to my mother at the mall, and on every female Olympian we saw on TV. But when my mother strode into the living room with my present, I felt my heart cave.
然后是我的生日。几个月来我一直乞求一双Riedell花样滑冰鞋。我幻想着自己用三重萨霍夫跳打动滑冰场小吃店后那个瘦瘦的、深色头发的男孩。我在商场里向妈妈指过这种鞋，在我电视上看到的每一位女奥运选手身上也指过。但当妈妈大步走进客厅拿礼物时，我感到心里一阵坍塌。
There was no way those skates could fit inside the thin manila envelope she handed me. I tore it open and found a letter from the Women's Reproductive Rights Assistance Project thanking me for my generous donation.
那个薄薄的马尼拉信封里无论如何也不可能装进那种冰鞋。我撕开它，发现了一封来自“女性生殖权利援助项目”的信，感谢我的慷慨捐赠。
"What is this?," I said.
“这是什么？”，我说。
"An abortion," she said.
“一次堕胎，”她说。“为一个在市中心遭轮奸的13岁女孩，以你的名义支付。”她语气中带着一丝自豪。“生日快乐。”
"For a 13-year-old girl who was gang-raped downtown, paid for in your name." She said it with a hint of pride in her voice. "Happy birthday."
我盯着她看。这是我的礼物？她甚至没有给我买堕胎。
I stared at her. This was my present? She hadn't even bought me the abortion.
“这个女孩什么都没有，”妈妈继续说，“没有家，没有钱，没有一个支持她、理解她生活最后需要的是一个孩子的出色的母亲。而这个组织给了她改变自己生活的机会。”
"This girl doesn't have anything," my mother continued, "No home, no money, no supportive, wonderful mother who understands that the last thing she needs in her life is a baby. And this organization gives her the chance to change things for herself."
“了不起，”我说。“我不知道贺曼公司还生产‘快乐堕胎卡’。”我往嘴里塞了一整个纸杯蛋糕，知道这只是个开始。
"Terrific," I said. "I didn't know Hallmark made a Happy Abortion card." I stuffed an entire cup cake in my mouth, knowing this was just the beginning.
我是对的。三天后收到一封信，来自艾米，那个我资助了堕胎的女孩，感谢我让她的生活轻松了一些。直到今天我都不相信该组织会允许我们有联系，或鼓励她放弃匿名。而且无论她否认多少次，我仍然认为那封信是我妈打出来的。但那天晚上，我太震惊了，无法争辩。
I was right. Three days later a letter arrived from Amy, the girl whose abortion I had funded, thanking me for making her life a little easier. To this day I don't believe the organization would have allowed us to have contact, or encouraged her to give up her anonymity. And no matter how many times she denies it, I still think it was my mother who typed up that letter. But that evening, I was too stunned to argue.
“给她回信，然后把信拿给我看，”妈妈说。
"Write her back and then show me the letter," my mother said.
当我告诉她，“我不知道该说什么”时，她把我送回西伯利亚带着笔记本，直到我想出点什么。
And when I told her, "I don't know what to say," she sent me to Siberia with a notepad until I came up with something.
那是周五晚上。当我爬进衣柜时，我幻想着朋友们在滑冰场，并怨恨我不得不给艾米写信。仿佛她是我的笔友，或者是某种我每天资助0.10美元餐费的非洲儿童。
It was Friday night. And as I crawled into my closet, I envisioned my friends at the ice rink and resented that I had to write Amy. As if she were my pen pal, or a child in Africa whose meals I was funding for $0.10 a day.
“祝你一切顺利，”我潦草地写道。但这感觉就像我在签某本陌生人的毕业纪念册一样。我想什么有什么区别呢？我讨厌妈妈那么执着于拉我入伙，因为13岁的我知道我的观点并不重要。但问题是，它们确实重要。对她来说。
"I wish you all the best," I scribbled. But that felt as if I were signing some stranger's yearbook. What difference did it make what I thought? I hated that my mother was so bent on drafting me to her side when, at 13, I knew my views didn't matter. But the thing is, they did matter. To her.
整个冬天每个周末和妈妈待在一起，我意识到作为一个单身母亲，住在狭小的单间灰泥公寓里，是多么令人沮丧。为了养活一个甚至不懂她从哪里来、可能根本不理解她的女儿而打两份工，是多么令人沮丧。所以我撕开一页纸。
What I realized spending every weekend for an entire winter with my mother, was how upsetting it must be for her to be this single mother, living in a tiny one-bedroom stucco apartment. Working two jobs to support a daughter who didn't even get where she was coming from, who maybe didn't understand her at all. So I tore off a new page.
“你真的应该感谢我妈妈，”我最后写道。和一个我不认识、可能根本不存在的女孩通信，仍然让我觉得是世界上最虚假的事情。但即使那时我也知道这封信到底是写给谁的。
"You should really be thanking my mother," I finally wrote. It still felt like the fakest thing on Earth to correspond with a girl I didn't know, and who probably didn't even exist. But even then I knew who this letter was really for.
我继续写道，“是她教我拒绝安全堕胎会威胁你的健康。而你的生殖自由是一项基本人权。”
I continued, "She's the one who taught me that the denial of safe abortions can threaten your health. And that your reproductive freedom is a fundamental human right. "
“基本”听起来太商业化了，所以我把它划掉再试一次。当我向后靠着思考下一行时，我想知道这些想法是否会开始感觉像是我自己的。它们还没到那一步，但我才刚刚开始。
Fundamental felt too businesslike, so I crossed it out and tried again. And as I sat back and worked through the next line, I wondered if any of these thoughts would begin to feel like my own. They didn't yet, but I was just getting started.
莫莉·安托波尔。她在斯坦福大学教授创意写作，目前正在创作一本短篇小说集和一部小说。
Molly Antopol. she teaches creative writing at Stanford University, and she's working on a book of short stories and a novel.
第四幕：裤子的启示。
Act Four. Pants Pants Revelation.
好吧，今天我们节目以一个关于两个有着不同、对立信仰的人的爱情故事结束。信仰，我相信，永远无法调和。一个是支持的，一个是反对的。一个是正面的。一个是反面的。
Well, we end our program today with a love story about two people with very different, opposing beliefs. Beliefs, I believe, that could never be reconciled. One of them was for, one was against. One was pro. One was con.
这个故事始于1990年。乔尔和凯特都在马萨诸塞州贝尔蒙特的一家精神病院工作。从他们相遇的那一刻起，乔尔就喜欢凯特，凯特就喜欢乔尔，但他们花了一段时间才搞清楚。在那期间，凯特花了很多时间思考如何讨好乔尔。
This story begins in 1990. Joel and Kate were both working in a psychiatric hospital in Belmont, Massachusetts. From the moment they met, Joel liked Kate, Kate liked Joel, but it took them awhile to kind of figure that out. And while that was happening, Kate spent a lot of time thinking about how to get in good with Joel.
我的意思是令人尴尬的是，基本上我每周都会查看医院的排班表，向前看七天，找出我和乔尔一起值班的班次。然后相应地规划我的穿着，因为我真的想看起来很可爱。我一直依赖的事情之一是，我有一条牛仔裤，我觉得穿上它看起来特别好。洗完衣服后，我会特意留着这条牛仔裤，等到我知道那天要和乔尔一起工作时才穿，这样我在乔尔面前看起来会非常漂亮。
I mean the embarrassing thing is that basically I would check the schedule at the hospital each week and look ahead to the seven days and find shifts when I was working with Joel. And then plan my outfits accordingly, because I really wanted to look cute. And one of the things that I always relied on was that I had this pair of jeans that I thought looked really good on me. And I would purposely save the jeans after laundry to the day when I knew I was going to be working with Joel so that I would look real fine in front of Joel.
她确实有一条我不太喜欢的裤子。这条裤子似乎与她的其他穿着不搭。所以它总是让我有一瞬间的失神。
She did have this one pair of pants that I wasn't totally crazy about. The pants seemed not in fitting with the rest of her. And so it always sort of threw me for a moment.
请描述一下那条裤子。
Describe the pants please.
嗯，它们是酸洗的。
Well, they were acid-washed.
它们太棒了。我爱死它们了。它们是酸洗牛仔布。有点像斑点白。踝部收口。有点像，不是灯笼型，但有点鼓鼓的。
They were awesome. I loved them. They were acid-washed denim. Sort of speckly white. Tapered at the bottom at the ankle. And a little bit, not balloonish, but a little puffy.
在大腿处像马裤一样鼓出来。而真正疯狂的部分是顶部发生的事情。它们有一个翻折的前部区域？
And they ballooned out in the thighs in a sort of jodhpur-y kind of way. And the sort of really crazy part was what happened up near the top. They had this fold over front area?
我认为让裤子看起来非常惊人的特征是它们顶部——你得试着想象一下——它们在你的腰部升得挺高。比如，天哪，肚脐上方四英寸？
The feature of the pants that I thought made them really amazing is that they had at the top-- you have to try to picture this-- they kind of came up pretty high on your waist. Like a good, gosh, four inches above your belly button?
OK。
OK.
但在最前面，它们卷成这个翻盖。这个大翻盖。它们非常酷。这些牛仔裤里有很多内容。
But at the very top of them in the front, they rolled over into this flap. This big flap. And they were just, they were very cool. There was a lot going on in these jeans.
你知道，我不想假装我是什么了不起的时尚达人。我不是。但那不是一条好看的裤子。
You know, I don't want to pretend like I'm some incredible fashion maven. I'm not. But these were not a good-looking pair of pants.
这些裤子的原始背景是什么？我脑子里出现的是乔治男孩演唱会。也许是“治疗”乐队？
What was the original context of these pants? I'm picturing a Boy George concert. Maybe The Cure?
正是。是的，你时间抓得准。我想我是在——我现在想起来了，我是在波士顿的一家店买的。大概是80年代末，87年左右买的，在那家非常典型的80年代波士顿服装店。它就是某种特定的造型。我的意思是，它绝对带有一点Bananarama的感觉，一点点乔治男孩。
Exactly. Yeah, you got the timing right. I think I bought them-- I remember now, I bought them at a store in Boston. Bought them probably late '80s or '87 something like that, in this store that was very kind of just '80s Boston clothes. It's just a certain look. I mean, it's definitely got a little of the Bananarama thing going on, a little bit of Boy George.
是吗？
Yeah?
但我当时还在把它们拖出来穿，因为我觉得它们穿在我身上看起来太好了，而且我非常喜欢它们。
But I'm still dragging them out at this point, because I'm thinking they look so good on me and I like them so much.
所以，我的策略之一是看看我们是否一起值晚班，因为晚班意味着我们作为一群人之后去喝啤酒的可能性更大。那是穿裤子的黄金机会。因为你穿上它，之后你们会去酒吧。就像那时候我有一整个晚上的时间穿着这条裤子，我知道我肯定会大获全胜，你知道吗？
So, one of my strategies was I'd see if we were working an evening shift together, because an evening shift meant we were more likely as a group of people to go out for a beer after. And that was like, that would be a golden opportunity to wear the pants. Because you'd wear them and then you're going to be out afterwards, in a bar. Just like I've got a whole evening of these pants at that point, and I know I'm going to be just gold, you know?
你还记得穿这条裤子的关键约会吗？
Do you remember any key dates where you wore the pants?
关键日期？那晚乔尔对我表现出兴趣，那是我们一起上晚班，然后一群人去酒吧的一个晚上。人群开始稀稀落落，最后只剩下我和乔尔。我那天晚上穿了——穿了那条裤子。那是一个非常成功的夜晚，因为那是他某种程度上向我抛媚眼的那晚，我知道这件事会向某个地方发展。他会约我出去。
A key date? The first night when it became apparent that Joel was interested me, was a night we had an evening shift and then a bunch of us went to this bar. And the group started dwindling and dwindling and dwindling, until it was left with just me and Joel. And I was wearing-- I was wearing the pants that night. And it was a very successful night because that was the night when he kind of, sort of was making eyes at me, and I could tell this is going to go somewhere. He's going to ask me out.
真的吗？所以你和你丈夫、你孩子父亲关系转折的那个夜晚，你穿着这条裤子？
Really? So the actual night that you turned the corner with your husband and the father of your child, you were wearing the pants?
我——是的，我是。是的，我是。那是真的。
I-- Yes, I was. Yes, I was. That's right.
那是你生活从曾经转变为现在所在的那个关键夜晚？
That was the pivotal night in which your life turned from what it was to what it is?
那是真的。那是真的。说得好。
That's right. That's right. Well said.
乔尔和我也开始约会了。我当时非常非常开心，因为他是一个出色的人，我不敢相信事情竟然成了，我们开始约会了。所以，我们继续，一起工作并约会。我想这时候大概有四个月了。
Joel and I began dating. And I'm just very, very happy at this point, because he's just a wonderful person, and I can't believe it's worked out, and we start dating. So, we're going along, and we're working together and dating. And it's reached, I'd  say we're at about four months at this point.
所以我们约会了四个月，但正处于那种我觉得有点像，你知道那个——我的意思是还没到非常严重的地步，但你知道这会持续下去，而且非常有潜力。你们显然都非常喜欢对方。所以我们到了那个地步，大约四个月，乔尔当时在我公寓里。
So we've been dating for about four months, but it's at that point where relationships get where I think it's kind of like, you know that-- I mean it's not super serious yet, but you know that this is going to keep going and this has a lot of potential. You're both clearly very into each other. So we're at that point, about four months, and Joel was actually over at my apartment.
凯特在她的卧室里，在她的公寓里翻看她的衣服，盘算着哪些该留下，哪些该捐给救世军。
Kate's in her bedroom, at her apartment going through her clothes and figuring out which ones she should keep and which ones she should give to Salvation Army.
我打开存放裤子的抽屉，把那条石洗裤子从抽屉里拿出来，完全不是因为我打算把它捐给救世军，而仅仅是因为我不得不移开它们才能找到抽屉底部的裤子，那些我可能会捐给救世军的裤子。当我把裤子从抽屉里拉出来时，乔尔坐在床上，在那坐了一会儿，清了清嗓子说——
And I opened up my drawer where I keep my pants and lifted the stone-washed pants out of the drawer, not at all because I was considering sending them to Salvation Army, but only because I had to move them to find the pants on the bottom of the drawer that of course I might send to Salvation Army. And as I pull the pants out of the drawer, Joel, sitting on the bed, kind of sat there a minute and cleared his throat and said--
嗯，你确定你要留着那条裤子吗？她停下来看着我说：“嗯，你知道。是的，我——当然，我的意思是，我想我会，为什么？”
Um, you sure you want to keep those pants? And she sort of stops and looks at me and says, "Well, you know. Yeah, I-- of course, I mean I, I think I do, why?"
所以我说，“好吧，你知道那些——我只是觉得那条裤子现在可能有点过时了。”
And so I say, "Well, you know those-- I just think those pants are maybe a little bit out of style now."
他说，“好吧，你觉得也许，你觉得也许它们只是没那么时髦了吗？”
He said, "Well, do you think maybe, do you think maybe they're just not in so much style anymore?"
随着话语出口，我看到凯特的脸涨红了。变得越来越粉，然后变红。
And as the words are coming out, I see Kate's face flushing. Becoming pinker, and then red.
我是说——什么？
And I was like-- WHAT?
她有点拿在手里看着它们，看着我，然后又低头看着它们。我意识到这些不仅仅是另一条普通的裤子。这些是——这些是特别的裤子。
She's sort of holding them in her hand and looking at them, and looking at me, and looking back down at them. And I realize these aren't just another pair of pants. These were the-- these were the special pants.
这对我来说是一个非常不舒服的情况，首先，同样，我自己也不是一个特别时尚的人，所以我大概没有权利对任何人说这个。但后来，其次，这是我真正爱上的女人，这是我第一次不得不对她说，关于你有些事——或者关于你连接的有些事我不喜欢。
And then I-- it's a very uncomfortable situation for me because, a, again, I'm not a particularly fashionable guy myself so I probably don't have any right saying this to anybody. But then, b, this is the woman who I've really fallen in love with and this is like one of the first moments when I've had to say to her, there's something about you or-- there's something connected to you that I don't like.
我简直不敢相信。这条我在他面前故意穿了这么多次的裤子，我以为它对我表现得那么好，他现在却说我应该把它扔进袋子里扔在路边。
I couldn't believe it. That these pants that had like, I've been purposely wearing in front of him for so many times, and I thought had done such a good job for me, and he was now saying I should put them in a bag and put them on the curb, basically.
你以为那条裤子真的对他产生过作用？你以为裤子是你军火库的一部分，是你对他掌控力的一部分？
You thought that the pants had actually done a job on him? You thought the pants were part of your arsenal and part of your power over him?
它们是——是的，军火库。正是。它们给了我自信，我认为这给了我对这个我最终想要吸引的人的一定程度的吸引力。因为显然，当我穿着那条裤子走来走去时，我感到非常自信。我觉得我看起来棒极了。
They were-- yeah, arsenal. Exactly. They gave me confidence, which gave me some, I think, some degree maybe of attractiveness to this person who ultimately I was trying to attract. Because clearly, when I was walking around in those pants, I was feeling pretty confident. I thought I looked great.
你觉得如果没有裤子你也能得到乔尔吗？
Do you think you could have gotten Joel without the pants?
哇。天哪。我甚至都不愿去想它，艾拉。我不知道。
Wow. Gosh. I hate to even have to think about it, Ira. I don't know.
你觉得裤子是那么大的一个因素吗？
You think the pants were that big of a factor?
我不知道！我不知道。我的意思是，那已经是11年前的事了，但也许那条裤子和它有点关系。你知道，我得问他。我得问他。
I don't know! I don't know. I mean, it's been 11 years, but maybe those pants had something to do with it. You know, I'd have have to ask him. I'd have to ask him.
如果她每天穿着廉价童装或休闲西装什么的出现，我也会爱上她的。我的意思是，正如任何恋爱过的人都知道的那样，你偶像化你爱上的人。特别是在初期，他们对你来说感觉是完美的。然后你开始问自己各种各样的问题。各种各样的不安全感涌上心头。为什么这个完美的人一定会爱上我，并接受我，想要和我在一起？
I would have fallen for her if she were showing up in Garanimals every day, say, or leisure suits or something. I mean, as anybody knows who's ever fallen in love, you idolize the person you're falling in love with. And they can, in those early days particularly, they feel perfect to you. And then you start asking yourself all sorts of questions. All sorts of insecurities come up. Why would this perfect person necessarily fall for me, and accept me and want to be with me?
但当你发现那个人完美中的一道裂痕，当你发现一个缺陷——在这个例子里，凯特至少在那条裤子上有糟糕的品味——它不知怎么地让你觉得更舒服了一点。你觉得，好吧，也许我确实有机会，因为，天哪，我的意思是那条裤子都有机会追到她。
But then when you discover a chink in that person's perfection, when you find a flaw-- in this case Kate had bad taste at least in this one pair of pants-- then it somehow makes you feel a little bit more comfortable. You feel like, well, maybe I do have a chance here because, God, I mean those pants had a chance with her.
乔尔·洛弗尔和凯特·波特菲尔德。自从那个故事2001年在我们的节目中首次播出以来，他们的家庭已经增加到三个孩子、两个大人，没有酸洗牛仔裤。
Joel Lovell and Kate Porterfield. Since that story originally broadcast on our program in 2001, their family has grown to three kids, two adults, no acid-washed jeans.
[音乐 - 吉米·克兰顿的《VENUS IN BLUE JEANS》]
[MUSIC - "VENUS IN BLUE JEANS" BY JIMMY CLANTON]
好吧，我们今天的节目由莉莎·波拉克和我制作，亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·凯尼格、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自安迪·迪克森。赛斯·林德是我们的制作经理。音乐协助来自杰西卡·霍珀。今天特别感谢朱迪·霍夫曼、安德鲁·所罗门和西蒙·约翰逊。今天还要感谢“我信”团队的工作人员，特别是维基·梅里克、约翰·格雷戈里和丹·格迪曼。
Well, our program is produced today by Lisa Pollak and me, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Our Senior Producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Andy Dixon. Seth Lind is our Production Manager. Music help from Jessica Hopper. Special thanks today to Judy Hoffman, Andrew Solomon, and Simon Johnson. And thanks today to the staff at This I Believe , especially Viki Merrick John Gregory and Dan Gediman.
旧的50年代时代的“我信”系列现在将在鲍勃·爱德华兹的周末节目中播出。而且在thisibelieve.org上有一个播客和全部65000篇文章。
The old 1950s-era This I Believes are going to be running now on Bob Edwards' weekend show. And there's a podcast and all 65,000 essays at this thisibelieve.org.
我在节目开始时谈到的杰伊·艾利森，正在从“我信”转向为公共广播制作一个全新的节目，《飞蛾广播时刻》，这将会像我们节目中多次节选的《飞蛾》讲故事播客一样，但今年秋天会整整一小时。
Jay Allison, who I talked with the top of this show, is moving from This I Believe to producing a brand new show for Public Radio, The Moth Radio Hour, which is going to be like The Moth story-telling podcasts that we've excerpted a number of times here on our show, but a whole hour this fall.
《美国生活》由国际公共电台发行。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
距离我们仅此一次的现场影院活动还有几天时间，届时我们将在舞台上与丹·萨维奇、迈克·比比利亚、乔斯·惠登、斯塔利·凯恩和其他人一起表演，并于本周四，4月23日向全国各地的电影院现场直播。你的时间不多了。门票在thisamericanlife.org。
And we are just days away from our one-time only live cinema event, where we are doing our show onstage with Dan Savage, Mike Birbiglia, Joss Whedon, Starlee Kine and others and sending it out live to movie theaters all across the country, this Thursday, April 23. You don't have much time. Tickets at thisamericanlife.org.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他确实不在乎公共广播在当前经济环境下是否会崩溃。他有更大的计划。
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who really does not care if public broadcasting collapses in the current economic environment. He's got bigger plans.
我正在考虑也许做心理咨询。另一件我正在考虑的是插花。
I'm considering maybe guidance counseling. The other thing I'm considering would be flower arranging.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多关于《美国生活》的故事。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
[音乐 - 吉米·克兰顿的《VENUS IN BLUE JEANS》]
[MUSIC - "VENUS IN BLUE JEANS" BY JIMMY CLANTON]
PRI。国际公共电台。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI. 公共广播国际。